هناك بعض التقدم ولماذا
نسميها بعض التقدم لأننا
كسرنا جمود عدم الاتصال
لبدء اتصال مع
السعوديين بصدق من وجهة
نظرنا ونريد أن نفهم
المظالم التي نريد دراستها في
نظام و  انظر إلى الحلول التي
يمكن أن تحمينا في المستقبل من أي
أزمة محتملة أخرى ، لذلك دعونا نلقي
نظرة على بعض الادعاءات الأصلية بأن
عائلة كاتيري المالكة قد رخصت
بتمويل الإرهاب عبر الشرق
الأوسط لعقود من الزمن ، أحد الادعاءات
تطالب بإغلاق قناة الجزيرة
لتقليل العلاقات مع إيران وإغلاق
قاعدة عسكرية تركية في قطر
وإنهاء الاتصال بجماعات مثل
جماعة الإخوان المسلمين ذكرت صحيفة وول ستريت
جورنال مؤخرًا أن
جزءًا من ثور الدوحة الوشيك كان
على استعداد لقطع العلاقات  مع
الإخوان المسلمين هو هذا صحيح أولاً وقبل كل شيء
نحن بلد لسنا حزباً سياسياً ،
لذلك قطع العلاقات مع
حزب سياسي لا أفعل  نفهم ما كانت
خلفيته ، لكن قطر لم
تدعم الإخوان
أبدًا ولم تكن لها علاقة مباشرة
بالإخوان المسلمين ، فهم كحزب سياسي
طالما أنهم يشاركون في
الحكومات التي انتخبها شعوبهم ،
علينا التعامل مع تلك
الحكومات.  يجب أن نتعامل مع
الأشخاص الذين يعملون في تلك
الحكومات ، وهناك أشخاص من تلك
البلدان مثل تونس ومصر ، هؤلاء
هم الذين يجب أن يُسألوا لماذا
يختارونهم ولم يختاروا
خيارًا آخر نعتقد في قطر
لا يمكننا إملائه  بالنسبة للآخرين ،
ماذا يختارون وماذا لا إذا
أردنا حقًا مساعدة البلدان ومساعدة
الناس ثانيًا فيما يتعلق بتمويل
الإرهاب ، وقد أثبت ذلك من قبل جميع
حلفائنا من قبل المجتمع الدولي
أن هذا الوعد لا أساس له
على الإطلاق ، هل يمكنك مشاركة ما إذا كان  أنت على
استعداد للتنازل بأي شكل من الأشكال ، وإذا كان الأمر كذلك
، فكيف وما هي مطالب القواطع التي تسير على ما
يرام ، أعتقد أنه من الواضح جدًا بالنسبة لنا هذا
الوضع  أيون ليس له فائز
، فقد نهض الجميع وتلك الأزمة ما نريد أن نراه
نريد أن نرى تسوية
تحافظ على كرامة جميع الدول
معلنين أن جميع الدول مالكة لهذه
الوحدة مرة أخرى وأن نكون متطلعين إلى الأمام
لحماية هذه الكتلة الخليجية.  من
أي اضطراب مستقبلي مثل ما حدث
في العامين الماضيين وأنت
تتجنب سؤالي ما الذي أنت
مستعد للتنازل عن مطالب القط الأخلاقي
منه ، كما أخبرتك أنه
لا توجد تنازلات نريد أن نكون
تطلعيًا ومطالبنا  أن
مثل هذا الموقف لا يتكرر مرة
أخرى ونقوله قبل أن نكون
مستعدين لمناقشة أي شيء باستثناء
الأشياء التي تؤثر على الملوحة أو
التدخل وسياستنا الداخلية أو الخارجية
، فهذه هي الأشياء الرئيسية
هل نحن على بعد أيام أسابيع أشهر
من  نهاية هذا عندما نعتقد
أننا ما زلنا في مرحلة مبكرة
للغاية وما حدث في العامين
ونصف الماضيين كان كثيرًا وهناك
أعتقد أن هناك حاجة لبعض
حان الوقت لإعادة بناء الثقة من جديد ، أنا أعمل
بخير ، نرى وزير الدولة
للشؤون الخارجية في الإمارات العربية المتحدة تغرد فيما
يلي التسريبات الخطية الأخيرة
بشأن حل أزمة الدوحة
مع المملكة العربية السعودية الشقيقة دون
الدول الثلاث ، هي تكرار
لمساعي الدوحة  لتقسيم الصفوف والتهرب من
الالتزامات ومضى يقول إن الرياض
تقود جبهة واسعة من إخوانها في
هذا الملف وغيره من الملفات الإقليمية
وتلتزم بمطالب
حلفائها وهذه مطالب أساسية وقوية
ردكم هل تحاولون تقسيم
الصفوف من خلال  فتح قنوات
اتصال مع السعودية
لسنا من وحدهم نحن دائما
نقسمهم
ومع احترام للوزير الذي قال
أن التسريبات المطلقة ليست تسريبات تماما
نتحدث بشكل واضح ومع
التصريحات الرسمية أن هناك بعض
التقدم الذي سيشهده.  هذا لذا لا يمكن تسميته
تسريبًا في المقام الأول وفي
حديثنا مع السعودية
نريد معالجة القضية التي أساءت إلى العلاقة.
شراكة بين قطر
والسعودية وأعتقد أن هذا حق مشروع
لكلا البلدين ،
ما نتحدث عنه الآن هو الحديث عن
المحادثات بين قطر والسعودية التي
ينبغي أن تؤدي إلى حل لأزمة دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي ،
نحن لا نتجاهل الآخرين ولكن
هذا  هي القناة التي بدأت
بالفعل وكان الضغط عليكما وكان علينا
إنهاء هذا الخلاف هو أنه من
أين يأتي نوع نقطة الارتكاز لهذا التقدم
جيدًا رأينا أن
حلفاءنا ليسوا سعداء
بالوضع في الخليج  ولسنا
سعداء بالوضع في الخليج ،
فلا نريد أن نقول إن
هذا نتيجة ضغط ولكن نتمنى أن
يكون ذلك نتيجة حسن نية
الطرفين للدخول في حل بناء.